is it hot in here you are hot
I am Donny Rock I am an adult male
performer I am Tori black and I'm here
with the lovely Kendra's Anna never have
I ever
we honestly have never played this game
before I always loose okay never have I
ever faked an orgasm in porn they're
always like come now so you're like one
time as I couldn't I'm just having a
rough day and I'm still bummed about it
I worked on a volleyball like a sand
volleyball courts Ruben fans we're gonna
leave that there yeah I got faking I
think come when I'm bored never have I
ever dated a co-star I don't know it
felt like it was messed with my
workplace I think about Hilary I knew
were missing my performance I say that
all the time
since I've got into porn I think you've
the same boyfriend and he has been in
one video before so I guess by default I
have totally against it but I have I
have not I have not I have not I have
not I'm not I'm happy
never have I ever gotten off two scenes
I'm in those are my favorite what all of
the time it's creepy it's creepy but I'm
like get it girl uh-oh me and my
boyfriend link to watch it but I would
never go back and like watch my own
video because I was just weird why do
people watch porn because it's their
fantasy so if I'm gonna watch it I'm
gonna watch myself and it's not a
fantasy it's real
actually I edit all my own scenes in
movie so when I'm editing a lot of the
time I have to masturbate never have I
ever slept with the fan it's a it's a
guest I don't know it's a boom and a
boom yeah I don't sleep with pins that I
sleep with people and find out their
fans later I guess I would say
oh okay it's this this is the confusing
we don't know I've been in the moment we
didn't know so it doesn't count I don't
think I have man I don't think not yet
it's never have I ever lied about my
profession yeah sometimes you don't want
to explain it unfortunately our industry
is incredibly stigmatized
sometimes I like those moments because
you can try to change somebody's mind
right but sometimes you just want to get
your groceries and go home so proud what
I have a thing that I do on the side and
I make furniture so I work in wood
technically there's not a lie
the deception I'm an event planner yeah
I'm a dentist never have I ever cut
there's always ways to spice it all but
I guess I've never gotten bored of sex
in general just a person or the actual
moment yeah and then I just first time I
lost my virginity actually I started
daydreaming because I'll pay attention
and then 30 seconds I'm like Oh looking
at the spider in the corner never have I
ever had a family member admit to
watching one of my scenes two of my
brother's my nephews have all told me
and if they watched my porn it was a
family member who really thinks I'm
going to burn in hell they're very very
religious my mama told me I made that
that's why you do a good like that I was
done when I go home for you know for the
holidays I'm like yeah I seen you little
movie I made that that's why you good
I'm like oh my god like mom right
we're okay I eat some turkey first so
did you learn anything today about
yourself about me I learned that you're
pretty cool
you're very open very sexy I have had
fun me through
[Music]